les cherry on à lenquête de baba sur
matthieu delormeau alors matthieu
delormeau nous avait agité la toile avec
un enchaînement de tweets avec plusieurs
personnes pour cible une salle de sport
et un attaché de presse
oui c'est l'heure d'une nouvelle enquête
de baba vous avez tous nous dira
sûrement vrai c'est pas drôle
regarde moi c'est pas drôle du tout
rires non mais yat ok je te le dis non j
s'invite pas ce que veut donner leurs
quêtes variées mais c'est vrai qu'on à
moi me dire quand même il ya un mois je
me fais sortir d'un taxi soit disant
parce que je suis gay et cette fois ci
je me fais sortir d'une salle de sport
c'est pas parce que l'on n'avait pas eu
d'accident ex égérie prendre cette
fois-ci maintenant ses racines sociales
parce que je suis aux émissions de
télévision
j'ai du mal à ces coûts le racisme
social ou alors on va on va regarder
l'autre mais il nous en parle après
regarde
lui c'est matthieu delormeau on pourrait
dire de lui qu'il est l'apollon des
animateurs télé
dommage qu'ils ne soient pas animateur
mathieu et chroniqueur médias dans
l'émission présentée par le michel
drucker de tunis cyril hanouna comme il
l'a prouvé depuis son arrivée dans
touche pas à mon poste pour matthieu
delormeau
il n'y a pas que le physique dans la vie
il y a aussi les muscles la beauté et le
boul
ils seront donc tous les jours à la
salle pour travailler ses pecs
ce féru de musculation a une
particularité il aime les belles choses
mais gratuite comme on dit dans le
jargon
c'est un rat une barre ou encore une
pince la preuve matthieu delormeau or
est appelée l'attaché de presse d'une
des salles de sport les plus chics de
paris pour se faire offrir un abonnement
en échange d'une promotion sur les
réseaux sociaux
salut bébé je veux juste savoir s'il ya
moyen d'avoir un abonnement gratuit pour
ta salle de sport c'est le chroniqueur
le plus viril de tpm p l'animateur le
plus cabot du paf réagi sur twitter
se considérant victimes d'homophobie
alors matthieu delormeau at il vraiment
été victime de racisme social
si mathieu ne peut accéder à cette salle
de sport où va-t-il bien pouvoir
pénétrer et surtout comment se fait-il
que tf1 qui nous veulent tous nos
talents nous laisse encore matthieu
delormeau
autant de questions auxquelles
l'inspecteur baba va tenter de répondre
[Applaudissements]
les jeudis vous avez été très touchés
vous adapter à l'oreille ce qui s'est
passé exactement parce que là il relate
l'histoire voilà mais la vraie vérité
alors mal et s'étaient moins bien
passées
la mañana tellement d'ailleurs qui
raconte des bêtises mais si je mens
vraiment de moi je vous crois alors elle
a coûté que sur mes neveux que j'aime le
plus au monde c'est pas drôle ou je te
dis que c'est vrai j'appelle donc le
lusine c'est une salle de sport
effectivement assez chic à paris il y en
a deux brefs
j'appelle jsk vous aurez un service
presse ils me disent très bien ce
monsieur s'appelle laurent guyot pour
l'appeler je l'appelle et préfère pas en
plus un pad je connais dalila c'est
sympa n'avez vous mais je pense avec les
puissants ou les gens chics mais pas
avec les gens comme moi et donc moi au
téléphone je lui dis juste voilà sam à
savoir est ce que c'est possible de
négocier avec vous une inscription je
n'ai jamais paraître gratuite et un
oncle et ma g où j'étais parfois vous
font des prix bref peu importe
en tous les cas c'est un service presse
est ce que ce sommet sera au club med
gym il n'a pas été au bout il a dit il
m'a dit je passe mon assistant vous fait
perdre du temps très bien ils passent en
insistant qu'il me dit envoyez nous un
mail mais ça a très peu de chances
d'aboutir et raccroche
je veux un témoin qui était à côté de
moi et le et qui dit attention il est
aberrant cette histoire je lui envoie un
texto pour lui demander et il envoie un
texto du temps mais tant et dont on a vu
comment tu as parlé à mathieu
qu'est ce qui se passe et il a répondu
telle qu elle parce que malheureusement
on a toutes les preuves que je n'aurai
donc à mon avocat il a répondu oui mais
c'est comme ça je le déteste
voilà et lettres il a répondu gratuits
ou payants ce genre de personne ne
mettra pas les pieds dans
l'établissement alors ce genre de
personne j'aimerais juste savoir de quoi
il parle j'ai rencontré de ma vie parce
que ce genre de personne je pense qu'il
est pas référence à la couleur de
cheveux
donc c'est soit à ma sexualité nom est
pardon j'ai terminé tous les jours de
personnes c'est pas du tout par rapport
à 6 alors je me suis un peu renseigné un
petit peu après visiblement c'est donc
pas d'homophobie c'est ce genre de
personne c'est que les crétins un peu
beauf qui le soir amuse les gens sur ces
8 et qui sont pas très chic ne vont pas
dans les salles chic parisienne donc
grosso modo si on est athée pmp ou
peut-être je ne suis pas si je suis trop
beau pour cette salle là alors ils sont
capables du racisme laissé un goût du
thé comme cory d'une boîte de nuit et
qu'on n'ose pas à le voir vous dis bah
tu rentres pas dans cette salle basse et
la mouche alors y'a pas de bofinger au
liban pour moi il ya aucun bouffe tout
ça c'est ray kay alors à mon avis c'est
vrai qu'il faut croire que je crois
qu'il est il ne vous aime pas mais ce
qu'on a le droit de refuser
oui c'est un attaché de presse ceinture
je comprends ce que tu ressens et tu
sais à quel point je t'aime beaucoup
mais je pense que si demain tu y vas
avec un chéquier tu dis donnez moi un
abonnement elle te donnerons grosso modo
ce qu'ils te disent et j'ai pas envie de
te faire de facilité à toi avec son
réseau parce que mais il ne te
refuseront pas si tu y vas et tu dis
donnez moi un abonnement ils te diront
pas non est-ce que tu penses julien que
le patron de cette salle de sport c'est
à nous de son attaché de presse que sa
communication très difficile d'arriver
seul qui à vis de droit ou de mort
j'appelle ça qui s'appelle ou n'importe
quoi ou le mauvais bus dans un taxi ou
n'importe quoi mais ce qui me choque
juste et je le dis alors j'ai appelé
après justin chante juste que oui en
deux mois j'ai vu des choses que j'avais
jamais vécu avant qui est que j'ai fait
une émission de télé impopulaire bah on
traite de beaufonds n'empêche on me
prend pour m'empêche de rentrer dans une
salle et je rentre dans un taxi le mec
se retourne et me dit wap et surmonter
xxe se dit je trouve juste que c'est
entre l'homophobie et le racisme social
j'accuse sais pas ce qui m'arrive
alors jean luc déjà quelque chose qui
m'échappe c'est à dire tu dis que tu
voulais pas négocier avec eux mais juste
pourquoi tu demandes le service presse à
ce moment là pourquoi tu avais pas juste
une cotisation mais et tu vas pas juste
le fait que j'étais abonnée à côté de la
bête du studio j'ai pas mal et ça baisse
de près sa mère et vous parce que vous
vous voilà à quoi moi pas de quoi non
c'est pas le sujet jean luc richard je
comprends tout à fait moi ce que tu as
vécu était super désagréable après ce
que je trouve c'est dangereux de dire et
de taxes est quelqu'un de racisme social
ou d'homophobie pas ce que c'est
je trouve que ce genre de personne je ne
sais pas pourquoi peut-être qu'il n'y a
pas ça ils t'aiment pas simplement
après moi je connais aussi cette
personne il se trouve qu'il s'est
toujours très bien comporté avec moi
dont et je fais partie de tnt comme toi
et donc de toute façon je pense pas que
ce soit le fait qu'on fasse partie de
tpm p non parce qu'il a dit qu'il nous
indique que cette un refus de vente sur
la gueule c'est ce qu'attendent les gens
ne pouvaient pas du tout c'est pas dit
envisager nivet tu ne fais pas porter
devant duclos qui j'ai envie de faire
des ristournes et cetera là tu fais pour
moi tu es à mathieu moi ça m'arrive aux
deux dans des stades de foot où parfois
on m'invite très gentiment et des fois
on ne vit pas quand on m'invite pas je
me dis pas que les gens sont anti
asiatique
c'est ça sert à rien non mais c'est ça
c'est quand vous fait un cadeau je le
promu cette volonté je suis très content
après si on ne le fait pas mais
précisons que je n'ai jamais rencontré
de ma vie mais c'est vrai que à la
rédaction qu'on a eu laurent guyot et
ses explications sont un peu bizarre il
ya une phrase le sait la tâche est plus
attachée de presse
il ya une phrase notamment qui dit il
nous explique que dans ces salles de
sport ils ont l'habitude d'avoir des
clients entre guillemets avec plus de
talent là avec plus de talent sénégal
alors les abris juridique et ce qu'il
veut oui parce que là on est un peu dans
l'univers du racisme social qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
de talent c'est une sorte de
discrimination juge les gens par niveau
on l'aimait mars trannoy l'ipv6 élèves
c'est un peu quand même
non oui mais cette cire il ya quand même
derrière tout ça de la discrimination
oui maintenant alors je vous dis j'ai du
talent pour les faire du sport juni
c'est un club privé est a priori je
crois qu'ils font ce qu'ils veulent oui
dans un club privé en fait ils peuvent
accueillir les gens qui veulent même si
vous payez
il a droit de vous dire non je veux pas
que toi dans ma salle il croit que ses
skis ça se passe comme ça comme un droit
d'entrée en voilà exactement après je
pense qu'il a un problème directement
avec vous oui mathieu oui mais voilà je
vous lis vous connais pas mme
apparemment ils regardent souvent
l'émission parce qu'il connaît vraiment
les missions il connaît tous les
personnages de l'émission chez qu'il a
demandé à valérie à jean-luc voilà de
son contrat mais je vous croyez qu'il
aurait refusé à vous vous êtes un homme
de pouvoir même vous avez messi manager
général sais de quoi tu es toi et que
les coutures noah n'en sais rien de fait
mais c'est la fédérale 3 laurent guyot
que je tu ils auraient refusé de parler
comme ça chronique - je veux un prix et
métiers
mais tout ce que j'ai eu l'envié aussi
ont vu non mais j'ai eu et moi j'ai
trouvé ça très bien de sa part parce
qu'il m'a dit la vérité magicien on est
apte le privé je vous le dis voilà il y
en a plein que j'aime beaucoup dans
l'émission
matthieu delormeau il se trouve voilà
que j'accroche pas avec lui voilà et et
que j'avais pas envie de l'aider en tout
cas à s'inscrire dans la salle de sport
c'est tout donc mais il n'a pas dit que
voilà il y là il a rien dit il a juste
dit voilà qu'il est pas envie d'aider
matthieu delormeau
c'était son explication est que voilà de
mine de rien il pour aider d'autres
personnes et m'a dit jean-luc valérie
girardi n'y a pas de problème voilà mais
là il a bien privé donc ils font ce
qu'ils veulent et et bien sûr y ait des
invités qui ne viennent pas dans nos
émissions presskits j'ai pas envie
d'aller avec ce guignol en parlant de
moi par exemple comme il m'est arrivé
aussi quand on me propose d'aller
habiter de dire mais non j'ai pas
tellement bien de juger quelqu'un dire
dire propose une salle petite taille ce
qu'il est ce que ces services est à dire
un tu n'es pas assez chic pour
l'émission et 2 tu n'as pas assez de
talent sur quoi on se marre tu n'as pas
unique talent par denis lapointe jugé
ton talent de tout cela c'est bien su
fait c'est bien ce qui les préoccupe
économie ce qu'il fallait dire que quand
enfin restaurant le restaurateur alors
il pourrait dire ta tête me revient
c'est ce qui se passe dans les bois
j'évoque des actions justice cirelli
nations les clubs privés ils ont le
droit par un mondial sert à mémé qui
mentent il dit je suis désolée c'est une
soirée privée touré le directeur général
s'est désolé tu es passé riche où tu es
trop noir ou tétreault nash house et des
raisons dégueulasse qui camoufle mais
c'est là le champ j'ai vraiment un truck
series à d'abord rappelé que tu l'a
appelée derrière et 2 vraiment vraiment
parce que franchement ça intéresse qui
trois personnes qui sont qui sont à
paris parce qu'en france c'est autre
chose à [ __ ]
mais je serais extrêmement touchant plus
à part qu'on en parle ce soir parce que
malgré tout toutes ces raisons là ce que
vivent les gens dans des boîtes de nuit
dans les taxis et tout ça et ben moi je
suis
2 - comme ça tu serais fixé en tout cas
mathieu sage qu'on soit toujours là pour
te soutenir mais je lui aurais tout cas
voilà ces études a montré que violet
appelé voilà c'est vrai est en tout cas
je vous dit ce garçon moi je m'entends
très bien avec lui il a toujours été
très sympa plus avec tous leurs potes et
je suis persuadé que ça va s'arranger
entre vous parle je vais l'attaquer on
verra bien ce que dira juste et c'est
dommage pour rencontrer d'abord et voilà
ta krabey d'accord à savoir sur chopin
ses téléspectateurs s'il vous plaît
comprenez vous le coup de gueule de
mathieu d'ormeaux non à 58 %
oui à carvin croissance c'était un bon
débat